o sea de la función dada por rd de tam
igual a 3 teta por el seno de tetas para
hacer o menor o igual a teta menor o
igual a 2 pin la gráfica de r en
coordenadas polares consiste en dos
bucles como se muestran en la figura y
lo podemos ver aquí cuando teta es igual
a cero
estamos en el origen después cuando teta
empieza a crecer empezamos a trazar este
primer bucle de esta manera hasta te da
igual la pib es decir trazamos este
primer bucle desde t t igual a cero
hasta tt igual a pin y ahora el segundo
bucle que tiene una r más larga se forma
desde 'the wall' la pyme hasta theta
igualados pin y si te preguntas por qué
no aparece acá abajo la razón es que
entre pin y 2 pin el seno de eta esto de
aquí va a tomar un valor negativo así
que le va a dar la vuelta aérea de este
lado y la magnitud de r es cada vez más
grande debido a este 3 de eta que está
multiplicando por lo tanto cuando te
tapa de pib a 2000 trazamos este segundo
bucle bien podemos continuar
se encuentra en la gráfica de r y el eje
y justo aquí lo puedes ver encuentran la
tasa de cambio de la coordenada x con
respecto a teta en el punto p bien
pensemos un poco en esto primero observa
que no tenemos a x como una función de
teta tenemos que encontrar esa función
según lo que nos dan así que vamos a
recordar un poco sobre las coordenadas
polares si este es nuestro ángulo teta
ésta sería nuestra red y así obtenemos
un punto en la curva para esta teta pero
cómo convertimos eso en xy es bueno
construimos un triángulo rectángulo por
aquí y si usamos el conocimiento de la
trigonometría básica podemos decir que
este lado de aquí que forma la base nos
da la coordenada x que va a ser igual a
la hipotenusa que es r por el coche no
de teta si quisiéramos la coordenada que
como una función de r y teta me quedaría
que ya es igual a r por el seno de teta
pero no nos vamos a preocupar por la
coordenada james ya que solamente nos
piden la corte
x bien ya tenemos esto pero ahora
tenemos todo en términos de teta así que
como la obtengo bueno pues vamos a
sustituir toda esta expresión por lo que
vale nuestro radio justo aquí y entonces
me quedaría que x de teta es igual
pero ya sabemos que él es igual a 3 teta
por el seno de teta por este coche no
detecta que teníamos al final y con esto
queremos encontrar la tasa de cambio de
la coordenada x con respecto a t está en
el punto p
por lo tanto encontremos la derivada de
x con respecto a theta para encontrar la
derivada del producto de tres cosas
podemos usar el mismo patrón que la
derivada para el producto de dos cosas
me quedaría primero la derivada de la
primera de las expresiones que es
simplemente tres por las otras dos
entonces es tres veces el seno de teta
por el coseno de teta
más y ahora voy a derivar la segunda
expresión y esa derivada la multiplicaré
por estas otras dos expresiones me
quedarán tres tetas por la derivada del
seno beteta que es el coche no detecta
por otro cosiendo de teta es un me dan
tres teta coseno cuadrado de teta ok
ahora voy a derivar la tercera expresión
ya esta derivada la multiplicada por las
otras dos expresiones pero cuidado la
derivada del coseno de teta es el menú
se note teta así que si multiplicas
menos seno de teta por tres tetas por el
seno de teta vas a obtener buenos
acomodamos menos tres tetas seno
cuadrado de teta y habrá que evaluar
esto en el punto p ahora cuánto vale te
dan en el punto p bueno en el punto p
vamos a un cuarto de camino así que
puedo decir que en el punto p de tabalet
y medios de modo que realmente lo que
queremos encontrar es cuánto vale x
prima
y medios y eso me quedara tres por el
seno de pi medios lo cual es simplemente
uno por el coseno de primeros lo cual es
cero por lo tanto de todo esto me queda
simplemente cero más tres primeros por
el coseno cuadrado de pi medios lo cual
es cero así que todo esto también es
cero menos tres primeros por el seno
cuadrado depp y medios pero el seno
cuadrado de pi medios es uno de manera
que esto es simplemente menos tres
medios a esto se simplifica todo y tiene
sentido decir que la tasa de cambio de x
con respecto a theta sea de menos tres
primeros bueno pues vamos a pensarlo si
teta crece un poco observa que x va a
decrecer así que tiene sentido que
tengamos este negativo por aquí con esto
acabamos el vídeo y nos vemos en el
siguiente